hi everyone my name is Sebastian thanks
for coming to my talk we'll talk to you
about transitioning your tools within an
organization so a few years ago by
company that's what we decided that it
was time to change our analytical
platform and the tools me were using and
so we're just going to walk them we're
just going to walk through why we
decided to change our tools how we
decided to which new tools to use and
then while we learn from the transition
now it's pretty neat because usually
when you go online you'll see a lot of
discussions about you know tool a is
better than it will be and so on but no
one really talks about hey how do you
make the jump from one to the other so
we saw this would be a pretty
interesting topic to cover it's a little
bit about my company in myself smashing
I very first crack technology we're a
marketing consulting firm based in the
San Francisco Bay Area we've been around
for 22 years so this story kind of
starts a few years ago when I joined a
company to start our data scientist
initiative and I've been there so for
years and I do data science I lead a
small team we are two currently but that
number changes pretty frequently
apparently so the before picture when I
joined the company it was very much a
traditional market research company and
the local needs or really don't have a
work that was being done was mostly
simple one offs in terms of statistics
and so they were just kind of run
frequencies means and so on this
analysis was being done by the project
managers and they wouldn't use entire
almost well entirely just spss and excel
so i think everyone knows excel how that
works how that doesn't work but spss is
kind of like SAS it's very much a
statistics oriented package it's very
limited but the little part it does it
does pretty well but there's no
scripting ability there's no for loops
there's just not that much to it
especially then I know they've recently
changed a bit their effort to make it a
little more programming help set
programming savvy i guess but they're
mostly really not python to do that
so I should tell you a bit about our
decisions so that was those are tools
and so what happened is we were started
to look at more serious data rather than
interest surveys we started to look into
client databases we also wanted to do
machine learning and other things and so
just kind of like the catalyst of the
choice was obviously article needs for
changing and anytime your analytical
needs change or the kind of work you
want to be doing changes you obviously
want to be putting a question if you
like this appeal of you want to be
putting in question the tools that
you're utilizing for that and as we
started to look into more and more
capabilities the limitations of the SPSS
excel combo became painfully obvious
like right like i said no scripting no
for loops which was a mess last thing
cost i don't know if you know but it's
PSS is twenty thousand dollars per user
per year so you know any time you're
considering reducing costs that was one
that would usually come up and if you
can come up with a viable alternative
you know it made my boss is really happy
so so these were really kind of what we
were facing that's that's when you're
looking to that and say okay we need a
new tool so what do we want out of the
new tool before we even started the
search the important thing was to define
what we wanted that new tool to do first
of all we wanted to replicate all
previous functionality right we don't
want any construction in our production
we want our project managers to be still
doing whatever they're due to do for the
project one of the clients of you
receiving the same thing we also wanted
to automate a lot of the very simple
work repetitive work that had been doing
going along so far so you know this is
one of the limitations of our previous
tool if we're getting rid of it we might
as well get rid of a main limitation we
had because SPSS was very much a manual
process and you know Excel is as well
obviously a lot of the stuff that was
being done was done by hand each time so
it was very error-prone you know you can
make a typo or something and minor Arab
rounding errors so anything that could
reduce that those kinds of errors would
be great we wanted consistency across
the teams everyone had their quirky
little way of doing their analysis
another little twist on it and what we
were looking for was an experience for
our clients would
the same products and deliverables
regardless of who they had been through
yeah if you wanted to improve our
efficiencies be a little more efficient
it's always something you should instead
of looking at your tools and because
we're a smaller company I didn't mention
a but we're about 50 total and these
tools and these platforms are being used
by roughly 20 ish people you know in
your that smaller group you do want to
maintain you know a single code base so
that collaboration can easily happen you
can share things and not place any
artificial bears an external mention a
little bit more about that later so here
were the initial contenders I'd used the
first one all the way the left is
wolfram mathematica which is a great
mathematical software if you've ever
used it but that's just what it is it's
a great mathematical software and so
it's not all that great for developing
having analytics things I know they're
also trying to spin it as they're very
capable doing big data type stuff it
also mostly relies on Python so we
quickly discounted it and then obviously
you know the big bar versus Python
Python thing now unfortunately for me
the name of the conference gives away
which tool we ended up going with I mean
obviously chose Python I do want to
quickly say for those were like more in
the our camp which pretty sure there's
not that many here but you know this was
being done a few years ago and I think
when i'll mention some of the factors
are was much more limited in those areas
than Python was so for the main factor
so first of all costs right if I looked
at the previous three mathematic I still
had a licensing costs versus you know
free for both r and python so that was
pretty simple but really when i'm
looking at the limitations and long-term
plans eventually we were looking not
only to build these capabilities but
also to make them more accessible place
them within widgets make apps and so on
and as long as you're creating some sort
of other infrastructure we want to we
prefer the system in which we could keep
everything in a single language so you
know if you're thinking about we're
going to create an entire web platform
you can do that in Python you could do
that in Python then oh and it needs to
interface with our sequel database and
some other stuff just in that sense it
was much easier to keep it all with in
Python than they would have
to keep it all with it are so that was
kind of dough really but in addition
obviously that meant all of our initial
goals and then lastly you know it was
mostly familiar with Python and this was
a project that I was mostly spearheading
so you know I'd rather go with something
that I was a lot more comfortable with
especially since a lot of it would rely
on educating others on it so that's kind
of how we chose those elements so how no
you know we know we need a new tool we
know what our tools should be based on
it's based on Python so our first
attempt there we go first attempt what
does that look like so again echoing the
same functionality that SPSS had which
was kind of like this notebook e-way so
you know it was pretty obvious we should
go with I python / Jupiter at the time
it was about to change names so you now
have a company full of people still call
it I hi I guess so it really was to
maintain that workflow and then to
supplement that we added our own custom
library which we called play-doh because
plato was Socrates student and basically
within it we baked all the functions
that I've talked about in terms of goals
it had a lot of our analyses turned into
you know functions it had a function
with it that would call to a database
and pooled data and so on so it really
had everything you would need so that
you just need that library and then I
Python so if this was if I was talking
about a diet how about it before and
after it would look like so this is a
CSS code quote unquote I guess syntax
Modi appropriate thing this is for one
method we use quite a lot which is pca
which is i mentioned reduction but the
part that's on screen I mean you can
even send the first part is kind of
reformatting it and as you can see
there's no for loops right like oh you
want to flan data you still have to
spell out every single variable and you
can forget one of them and it won't tell
you forgot one of them until you know
your numbers look frog so it's pretty
awful and so this is how we replicate it
that entire functionality so it's very
clean very simple you know import
statements I put it place in Port pan
me because it's not become a habit not a
bad ones have I guess but yeah you know
just the first line is pull the data
from the database for this project the
second one is run pc on these variables
clean simple you just met all the goals
the next piece was our propagation
strategy so this is kind of what the
typical project structure looks like we
have a project lead who's our client
contact you know can oversees everything
we have a project manager who makes sure
the project is on track and then we have
all sort of research associates who do a
little of the groundwork right so when I
was showing that SPSS code they would be
the ones writing it under the
supervision of a project manager so
really our idea was to go from the
bottom up and slowly transition the
toolset so from the entry level people
and then kind of as they would grow
another people would grow we would move
up to the next stage and so on so that
eventually you know all this blue boring
SPSS squares became magical green Python
ones so we went through when did that in
some successes you know as I mentioned
we managed with our library to make
everything into simple one function or
couple function calls simplify the
workflow quite a lot obviously now that
everything was pretty much fully
automated it went really fast but there
is also no errors because human
involvement was reduced to an absolute
minimum which I found many times is the
only way to guarantee almost zero errors
and yet turnaround times and obviously
to supplement kind of the knowledge even
within the library we had written a
pretty comprehensive documentation with
a lot of examples I don't know if you're
visiting like I guess we kind of copying
on the numpy / pandas documentation or
even if you pull the doc string within
the doc string there's five examples
with you know input output type things
and that actually helped us quite a lot
it helped people you know to have
examples of the code in there so that
was like our big successes the issues we
run into so writing a Python library is
easy as everyone will tell you writing a
good maintainable future-proof library
is very hard and so you know someone who
was mostly trained in terms of writing
models that would work you know my data
science background
physics basically that and also support
you know before people had issues with
spss do it pick up the phone call IBM
and someone will walk them through their
problem or just given the solution here
you know even though you can copy paste
the error message into Google and get 15
Stack Overflow arguments over which
solution is the best you still have to
go through them and decide on
implementing so we have to counter both
of these issues by hiring someone in
helping us out you know manage the
codebase clean up all my slope sloppy
code because there was quite a few
not-so-great things that worked but
whenever reeling future-proof things
that just work or not necessarily the
best and also helped out a lot with the
support in the training but really the
main issue that we ran into when trying
to deploy this is that nobody wanted to
use it and that's a pretty big problem
because she's saying hey here's a new
tool anyone goes it looks neat and then
never mind i'm going to go back so more
nobody liked it the first one is pretty
simple and I guess someone works in the
marketing company we should have seen it
coming it's perception so when I think
of Python right or I guess like any of
us in this room this is what we think of
we think of all these amazing libraries
have been out there you can think of
like all the nice and awesome ways you
can combine them and create brand new
things you know this is I mean this is
really like why I say I think this is
really what I think of when I think of
tyfa right this is just this magic
magical simple language that gets
anything and everything done and it's
just the best for non-technical people
this is what Python looks like this is a
fun fact this is from the different
constructor with tennis library but you
know they really see it as like even if
you try to sell it to them as this
magical simple tool they still see it as
this technical programming language that
is complicated and you know has classes
and subclasses and definitions and for
loops and they're just they're very put
off by it so there's first of all like
this initial barrier of adopting a new
tool that seems very much intimidating
the second part was the propagation
strategy that I mentioned earlier so
when we were actually at the stage and
we started to introduce
the language to the lower level people
were actually you know the ones mostly
using these and who were kind of send me
happy to be using it I mean afraid to be
touching this thing but really what was
going on with this we basically created
this barrier between the low-level
people and the project managers who are
still in the old tool and as a result
could not necessarily oversee as well
what the research associates were doing
and so obviously project managers and
project leads we're not happy that the
you know people who are supposed to be
helping them we're using a tool that
they had no idea how to work with how to
control how to proof you know how would
you improve that work you know well this
new guy the company tells you this is
air proof but how do you really know so
that also created a lot of resistant
within you know within the rest of the
organization for the propagation of that
tool and then just kind of like some
last they weren't as big drivers of it
but also issues as well you know there's
some resistance some people had been
working there or in the field for
10-plus years and had been using spss
and you know they were just very happy
with SPSS for 10-plus year and why all
the Sun have to spend time thinking of
this new tool obviously you also need to
train people to start using these new
tools and you know one sku four hits in
the marketing world that's when the
busiest time of the year wraps up the
dick starts and you know come
september-october no one has time for
training sessions so here's a tool you
tell them we'll save them a lot of time
but they don't even have the time to
think about it also the implementation
the way we approach it we assume that
everyone would be as comfortable and
friendly with Python you know as we were
turns out that's necessarily true it's a
little bit covered by the perception but
also some people have a little more
trouble understanding programming you
know
kind of mentality and lastly there are
some people which is not happy about you
know losing the ability to their little
work and they felt like they were giving
up control over how analysis was being
done and at the same time we were to
control with them but we weren't really
offering them you know a trade-off at
all even you know saying well instead of
control here's what you get we're just
saying tough luck you know it's the way
it should be done that statistics do not
belong in this company but you know it
still is not a conversation they would
enjoy really having so just kind of wrap
up everything that didn't really work
with that pythons intimidating for
non-programmers your propagation
strategy should not include barriers
especially when up front you thought
about hey I should create a system that
doesn't lead to internal barriers and
then you create a system that leads to
internal barriers that gets should have
seen it coming obviously you need to
think about realizing their transition
is a time and f you know time and effort
rich process in it it does need to take
time and it does require a lot of effort
and you know people realize that that
effort is there and if you offer them
something that slightly just as easy or
slightly easier that effort is not going
to be worth it to them and to aggravate
things people tend to overestimate the
effort required do something new and
underestimate the benefits from it which
again as someone works in the marketing
company should have see coming so what
do we go live from there well you know I
after a few heated discussions within
the company you know we have to rethink
the strategy in the approach and that's
where you know you kind of have to start
from scratch and go okay well let's go
at a different way and see what we can
improve on it so second attempt so just
kind of like resume obviously our goals
were always the same initially the
initial ones still apply we still want
this to be the same we wanted to be
automated when you see
airs but really what we were trying to
do now in the second round was make it
simple to use to the users and then make
it a lot more approachable we wanted
this to be like this friendly nice easy
solution that it would be a no-brainer
that you would do over spss so this is
really especially the last 2 and here
they're bolded really they were the
driving kind of considerations we had in
the second way around so um somehow we
just had the crazy idea of putting
everything in a web portal and so this
is kind of what it looked like at the
beginning unfortunately can't show their
current version of it because its
proprietary but it was called work so
because one of persons on the team
thought it was so funny that the word
internment for to literally translates
as work thing but so basically what we
have here is you know every interaction
was through a simple web GUI each means
each screen would carry very simple
instructions kind of again thinking of
like how we had the documentation on
there but this time you know it just was
a Jew I which we're all familiar with
writer you know what you know what a
drop box and stuff like that loves the
output also we made it so it would for
instead of just giving you tables the
way that you know pandas would return
like a data frame or so on really the
idea was to get that output as ready for
the final report as possible so that in
addition to not only being used simple
to use and friendly and fast when you
got the result all you really have to do
was copy paste something straight into
PowerPoint you know and you would have
it and it would be there and then
obviously we simplified as much as
possible and kept every single page
single function just stressing on the
simplicity so here's a ways in which it
contrasts from the previous attempt you
know web GUI no need for training
whatsoever right you just go on the page
I think the most effort you have to do
is periodically send out an email to
everyone saying hey we add it when you
like here's the new website through
which you can do this thing we also
change the propagation strategy instead
of going by different levels and
creating those barriers that I was
mentioning we distributed these tools to
the entire company all at once but to
not overload them we basically
introduced each function
any piece wise so that basically people
were just getting acquainted with the
interface if for later versions we
needed to improve something else it
would come up but it would only affect a
small piece of it you know just more and
more it became this thing that was more
and more compelling to use we also
realized that you know you can't
immediately get rid of the previous
version and just ask if we want to be on
this platform like we had done entry
level people so at that point we started
to reduce the number of likes and if
SPSS licenses that were available but
not removing them all together for
instance and we're still kind of in that
process but we have you know we've gone
from having 20 licenses of the stuff to
just to which $20,000 twenty thousand
dollars a pop is pretty great effort
already and so not only were we
replicating all functionality we were
also starting to introduce new
methodologies that as the science team
we had developed and now we were giving
it to the hand of a teams and not just
saying hey contact us and we'll do this
for you it was a case of hey here's some
somewhere where you yourself can do that
and that was a trade-off we offer you
know an exchange of taking over taking
off taking control off of their hands
and these were pretty these reasons were
actually pretty compelling that actually
worked a whole lot better so again just
stressing out this is what an input page
would look like you know recent body
just choose your files there's just an
instruction quickly that tells you hey
this is what the file the formats it
should be in and what the file should
include just make it really simple and
again just to make it even more friendly
we added a few notes of humor this is
what a loading screen looks like
actually it's like the shark dancing and
so this this new tool really worked
really well so what were the main
lessons for us like I said changing tool
requires a transition period you can't
expect to come up with something better
and then everyone will go oh my god this
is the best and I'll just use that you
know like you slowly have to be weaned
off the previous one and introduce soon
and you want you obviously as you
develop these tools and that's something
that I mean I was particularly guilty of
and I think we're all kind of guilty of
it in this data science world is mean to
keep in mind the users and their
perceptions we all love it
stats but really these things need to be
boiled down to you know what it is that
our end users care about this is
thinking about the consultancy world
right like I will run models for clients
and find statistically significant
findings or not but in the end my client
doesn't care all that much they just go
oh is this a good idea yes or no and so
this is really something that is but
even internally you have to think about
if you know what is what is it that they
really care about from the tool do they
really care about the simplicity or does
it just want easy nice results and so I
mentioned that the output was nicely
formatted with them and they cared a lot
more about the nicely formatted output
than the fact that this process was
turned from 15 steps you just to also
open source doesn't mean three it is
also something that we learned you know
I guess anything in code and supporting
will require time will require resources
and even though there's not explicit
cost there's still cost that you will
incur and that you should take into
consideration within your company I mean
we're mostly lucky that SPSS is a tool
that's horrendously expensive but if
you're mostly relying on something
that's costing you that much not that
much but you know helps out the support
or stream lines that in some other level
you have to consider that train off and
then obviously whenever you introduce
any tool it has to be worth it for the
end user you have to make it that much
easier for the users has to be worth it
for them and some sort of trade off
which I get also something that we had
not considered at all so for future
plans there are also some other elements
we haven't fully responded to yet as
we're building this tool where obviously
you know working on in optimizing it but
we also have now the weird case of power
users you know the ones who enjoyed
using spss and all its you know to get
it to do this one weird obscure thing
and so for that we're actually working
on getting some sort of ipython server
in the background that can also be
accessible from that platform you know
and then that way we can control their
environments because there is such a
thing as knowing just enough to be
dangerous and we have put officials in
my company but yeah so we're also
thinking about putting some sort of
system for them to use improving the
layout and arrangements I think we're
all familiar with that that's just you
know we're obviously tracking
help you for using these tools and
improving them and if the nice thing
with our solution is that as a web thing
you can be constantly updating it and
we're constantly adding new tools and
new capabilities right now we're into
this huge foray into a text analytics
actually and it's it's really nice at
all of a sudden you know for the teams
they're able to do pre advanced text
analytics from this simple screen and I
think the next thing because people care
so much about output being nicely
formatted we're also looking into more
advanced charting and reporting tools I
think some clients have expressed
interest in receiving these dashboards
instead of reports so we're also kind of
using that as a platform to improve to
improve kind of our deliverables which
is a nice unexpected consequence of this
entire effort so yeah thanks a lot
that's overview of how we did it if you
have any questions yes ah the website
itself well that case it could be built
at piecewise I think it took about a
month to just get the template going and
then a lot of these are being generated
with Django and ginger so that you know
you just have the elements and then the
output pages because the charts have to
be generated each time so yeah it also
avoids us from knowing that it also
avoids the need to know too much jas or
HTML development which do not want to
get into think I've heard that a lot
this is her we can just I don't want to
do Jaso yes
oh yes so there there's a lot of
functions like people would take
questions especially from our survey
database there's there's a few ways that
questions are being formatted that in a
database nights that make a lot of sense
but then once you need to start working
with the data it's a little more
annoying to put it mildly so there's a
lot of transformation of grouping things
and turning them into a single table so
for instance that entire process is just
automated you just point it out to the
right point you know that you tell it
hey do this transformation on these
questions and it outputs the perfect
table that people want it also formats
things in the way that is the way we
like to see them within the company I
know stat testing between start testing
between numbers sometimes it's we do it
with like adding a letter at the end of
the percentages and obviously because
that's our way of getting it eternally
no one else does it so we bake that in
into that library as well and then I
mean now the plate even though like we
took it off of their hands we're still
maintaining it as the backbone of that
web platform so now it has our pricing
evaluations it really has like all of
your methodologies built into it yes
easier nowadays fewer nurses are
elaborate look out pretty well these are
you making the baseball are you think
that transition
um mmm that's a good one f especially
when I was preparing for this talk and I
was the one reason I was going to talk
about that Oh Python just does web stuff
on its own a lot of people like well so
those are now right so that i don't know
i think so i still think really you know
that picture of like how are you flying
python it's still kind of how it keeps
that in mind if you know it's there for
added a lot of things to art but in the
end it's just some sort of analytical
tool as opposed to a programming
language on which you know entire
companies have built everything they do
so I mean if your scope is limited you
know and you know it's going to have
some limits and it has to play with
other elements are already built in I
mean yeah I think there's a better case
for our vs Python if you know eventually
you hope that the entire organization
will run on it and it will plug into a
lot more different things I think Python
still has a bit of an advantage yes
yeah we have an internal so obviously
like we like or the design team and some
of our programmers are tripping to the
code base we have a internal git server
because again unfortunately one of the
downsides of being a consultant is like
some of your clients require everything
to be on premises and that kind of stuff
so we have an internal get server and so
will do you know regular push polls will
have code reviews and so on that's
actually helped quite a lot and then
celac also it's pretty great for talking
code over with other people all right
well thanks everyone for showing up for
my tie